At some point, these behaviors are fostered by a culture
that promotes individual gain over collective progress.
So if we're going to uproot corruption,
we have got to start before it ever takes root.
We have got to intervene early.
I don't know about your country,
but where I come from,
youth will lead us into the future.
In Kenya today, 80 percent of the population is under the age of 35.
But by their own admission, they have conflicting values.
Fifty-eight percent of young people in Kenya recently told us
they will do anything to make money.
An additional 45 percent said
corruption is a legitimate tool for doing business.
Seventy-three percent
said they would not be willing to stand up for what they believe in
for fear of retribution.
What I learned from my mother
a few years ago
was this concept of "the power of one" --
that each of us can be potent agents of change
and that together, we are a force,
that if we put our hands together, we can change the situation
and no problem is too big.
My mother understood this so profoundly
that it was at the center of her work.
Shifting cultures takes patience, persistence and commitment,
and it is extremely slow and deep work.
But if we are going to shift a culture, we have got to get that work started.
And in the time since her passing, we have established a foundation in her name
to do exactly that
but to work with young people and children
to begin to build character and personal leadership,
to inspire purpose and integrity.
But fighting corruption is not as easy as saying corruption is bad.
Now, here are three strategies that we are employing
that we believe can be replicated in any school community.
First, we must understand the why:
Why does corruption happen in the first place?
Do we call it for what it is -- theft --
or do we gloss over it with other words?
When young children are able to model what it looks and feels like
to deal with corruption,
they are likely, when faced with a dilemma in their future,
to model what they've been taught.
Second, we need to teach character explicitly.
Now, this may seem obvious,
but a child who exhibits a growth mindset
and a sense of self-control
is self-confident.
And a self-confident child is likely to stand up for what they believe.
Third, we need to build personal leadership in our children early
to give them an opportunity to know what it looks like
to call corruption out when they see it,
what it feels like to stand up and be counted when they're needed
and, for me, to make the more and most important connection
between human suffering on one hand
and corruption, greed and selfishness on the other.
We have got to believe in our capacity
to bring about the future we want to see,
each of us in our small way.
Young people must believe
that a new reality is possible.
Corruption, climate change,
ecosystem collapse, biodiversity loss --
all these issues need leadership.
And in the words of Baba Dioum of Senegal,
"In the final analysis,
we will conserve
only what we love,
we will love
only what we understand
and we will understand
only what we are taught."
Thank you.
(Applause)